ma ciao più titoli di stato sono usciti
un po sfocate lì perché anzi un'oncia
poco la webcam perché con l'iphone non
sono gli stanno questi video per quale
motivo mi sento ancora un cavetto della
videocamera chiede morì migliora
arrivare il titolo il problema è che non
vedo quello che sta succedendo ma spero
che stia registrando in questo momento
era tanto non lo so neanche bella tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
che sono familiari lo sfocato delle di
video di attiviste scuola di vita di
oggi del round pick up perché lo leggete
la titolo è perché sto provando a rifare
la stessa cosa che avevo fatto qualche
settimana fa ovvero la prima volta che
mi capita di morire finisce il video
ma questo nel primo episodio adesso
facciamo col sanguinamento nel senso che
mi basta sanguinare
una volta per terminare il video ragazzi
impossibile già lo scorso video sono
morto subito il video durato due minuti
qua manco lo avvio
speriamo di resistere vorrei fare una
roba evitando che ci si possa sanguinare
prima che non solar tromba quando san
guido io non gli altri ok il video
finisce la proviamo ok
la donna gia e se mi tornavano sono già
morto allora posto a posto a posto forse
questo potrebbe durare in camerun
livello forse lo faccio forze non è che
voglio tirarmela non sono riuscito a
farlo ma non fa niente meno un livello
11 possiamo farlo some si chiama come il
mio cane con la laggiù al piano ragazzi
piano salto it89 negozio sai ma torna
nora guy difficilissimo c'è un'ansia che
ha visto gioco sanguini è come camminare
il tuo gioco dominare quindi ce l'ho
fatta
[Musica]
no